in several videos we have talked already
about the price elasticity of supply in
this video we're going to dig a little
bit deeper and we're going to think
about what factors might make a supply
curve or supply schedule or portions of
it to be more elastic or inelastic so
we'll think about the determinants of
the price elasticity of supply and to
help us think about that I've drawn two
different supply curves and so remember
price elasticity is thinking about how
sensitive is the quantity or the price
elasticity of supply we're think about
how sensitive is a percent change in
quantity supplied to a percent change in
price so for example if we were to go
from this price to this price it's a
pretty significant percent change in
price it looks like about a fifty
percent change in price but if we look
at this supply curve where it's getting
pretty vertical it's not quite vertical
yet but it's getting pretty steep our
percent change in quantity is going from
here to here so it's not as dramatic so
these parts of the curve that are
relatively steep as they're approaching
more and more vertical we would consider
those to be relatively inelastic if you
had a perfectly vertical or portions of
this curve that were perfectly vertical
at those portions you would say that you
have perfect in elasticity and then if
on the other hand in this example if we
were to change our price from say this
to this that's a relatively small
percent change in price but notice it
could result in a fairly large percent
change in quantity supplied we're going
from this to this so when we are more
horizontal or the flatter our supply
curve is that would be we're talking
about relative elasticity or we are much
more elastic here than we are there so
elastic and if you were perfectly
horizontal then you would have a
perfectly elastic part of our supply
curve or our supply schedule now what
would cause what are the factors that
would make us get more inelastic or more
elastic well let's think about a
situation let's say we are in this world
let's say we are in the world starting
at this price where this is our quantity
I'm
that the factories that produce whatever
good were talking about here they're
already at full production and to have
to make more production would take a lot
of time or there might not even be the
resources to have more production maybe
the people who make the factories are
doing other things right now maybe you
have other resources other inputs into
your production that there's just not
more of maybe oil is as much oil in the
world as being produced and that's an
input into production and so in that
world even if the price is even if the
price goes dramatically up people might
want to produce a lot more quantity but
they just can't they don't have more
factories or they don't have more inputs
to produce them
so the quantity might go up a little bit
they might run the factory they might
they might run the factories in overtime
or the the people who are trained to do
that skill and maybe they're there just
aren't a lot more people who can do that
skill they're working overtime but they
can't produce a lot more and so a couple
of things that we can glean from that
example is this in the elasticity of
supply tends to happen in the short run
when in the short run you're not going
to be able to build a new factory in the
short run you're not going to be able to
find more sources of let's say oil in
the short run you're not going to be
able to train a lot more people to
produce a lot more in the short run so
if we're talking about a supply curve
that's describing more of a short-run
timeframe then it tends to be more
inelastic and then the other thing is
and we already talked about this is
there's not available resources or not a
lot of available resources not a lot of
available available resources once again
your factories operating full-out you've
hired everyone who can produce that
thing you're producing or some natural
resource that you need as an input into
to make this good well the world is
already producing as much as they could
well let's then go to the other
situation what would cause elasticity
well this could be a world where in the
long run it might be easier to get more
resources in the long run you can build
more factories you can find and hire and
train more people
so the longer-run that we are talking
about that tends to lead to a more
elastic supply curve in the longer run
and then another notion here is that you
aren't capacity constrained or maybe I
should say aren't resource constrained
aren't resource constrained so maybe our
factories are running nowhere near
capacity so even a small increase of
price or subway I'm gonna just make my
factories around a little bit more or
there might be a lot of people who can
help produce who have the skills to do
to produce that good so as the price
goes up more and more people are going
to start producing that good or it might
be using resources where there's no
shortage of it where as the price even
goes up incrementally people will just
use more and more of that resource to
provide more and more of that good